Kim Kardashian turns 38 the beauty
moguls huge family and friends Center
some major love on social media I love
that Kim's husband Kanye West surprised
her by decorating their home with
beautiful floral arrangements hanging
from the ceiling he shared the sweet
sentiment on Twitter writing your
stunning I will keep trying to make
things that can express how beautiful
you are inside and out and how much I
love you and our family
[Music]
the former assistant and friend
Stephanie Sheppard's took to the gram to
share a montage of photos videos with
the birthday girl while Kim's bestie at
La La Anthony posted this pic writing
happy birthday Kimmy wishing you the
best day ever
here's to another year of crazy
adventures and lots of laughs or just
getting started
love you long time friend Jonathan
Cheban honored her neon moments in Miami
calling Kim perfect
and a legend it was such an exciting
thing Chloe couldn't help but gush over
her big sis sharing several pics and
writing this sweet note my entire life
you've always been someone that I look
up to to me you are superwoman I'm so
thankful for us getting closer over the
last year without you I would be lost
look at this gift from my mom Kris
Jenner celebrated her daughter's
birthday by buying jewelry for her teeth
and honored her with a collage of pics
on Instagram captioning them in part you
are the best mom wife sister daughter
and friend and I am beyond blessed to be
your mom it's never a dull moment
longtime makeup artist Mario dead
Ivanovitch shared sweet photos of an au
naturale Kim writing you're never
entitled or act like the world owes you
something you take control of your own
life and destiny and you firmly hold the
pen that writes your life story it
really is a game changer
Kim's younger sister Kendall posted
heartwarming old home videos of her
beautiful sister
she is a lounging around because she
knows she's gonna have a big school year
[Music]
while Kylie shared a throwback of the
sisters kkw ex Kylie makeup collab
[Music]
Kim thanked everyone who sent their well
wishes and revealed her dream birthday
celebration on her own account filling
chocolate chip if mom and dad gave me a
diamond heart necklace with these little
pearls and it is so cute I still have it
so pretty and really just special it's
really lit and fun and crazy happy
birthday Kim Kardashian